The Genome Browser contains tracks that we can
use to visualize regions of the DNA that are
transcribed into RNA. This type of data can provide
strong supporting evidence to the hypothesis that
a certain region of a genome codes for a gene.
Let's look into the RNA-Seq tracks section
of the Genome Browser to visualize this type of
data. We are once again using the July 2014 (Gene)
assembly of D. melanogaster and focusing on contig1. The RNA Seq Tracks section contains results
from sequencing mRNAs and then mapping these
sequencing reads against the genome. Hence, regions
with RNA-Seq read coverage usually correspond to
regions in the genome that are being transcribed.
To visualize the RNA-Seq read coverage data, click
on the  RNA-Seq Coverage link under the RNA Seq
Tracks section to open another window in
order to specify the settings for this track.
Change the Display mode to "full." Change the
Data view scaling field to "use vertical
viewing range" setting, and change the "max" field
under the Vertical viewing range section to 37.
Unselect the Adult Males track under the
List subtracks section, and then click "submit."
By unselecting the Adult Males option, the genome
browser will only show the RNA-Seq read coverage
from the Adult Female sample. If we did not
unselect the Adult Males option, the default
would be to display both the female and male
data as two separate subtracks on the Genome
Browser. In addition to RNA-Seq coverage, it is
often also helpful to consider splice junction
prediction data that are derived from the subset
of RNA-Seq reads that span two or more exons,
known as spliced RNA-Seq reads. To visualize these
predictions, click on the Exon Junctions link
under the RNA Seq Tracks section, use the drop
down menu to select "pack," and then click "submit."
We can examine the splice junction predictions
more carefully by zooming into the five prime and
three prime end of the exon. Several other tools
can help us analyze splice junctions. TopHat
is a program that can identify splice junctions
without relying on a database of known junctions.
TopHat first identifies potential exons by
mapping segments of RNA-Seq reads to the genome.
because RNA-Seq reads are short sequences derived
from processed mature mRNA, they will often align
contiguously with an exon. However, some
RNA-Seq reads will span multiple exons
thus containing valuable information about
splice sites, TopHat builds a database of possible
splice junctions followed by mapping the actual
sequencing reads against these predicted junctions.
This method allows us to find novel splice sites,
aligns RNA-Seq reads to the genome assembly, and then
analyzes the mapping results to identify the
splice junctions between exons. To illustrate,
let's view the RNA-Seq data for
a different Drosophila species.
Click on the Genomes link on the main menu bar
to return to the Genome Browser gateway page.
Change the genome field to "D. biarmipes,"
the assembly field to "April 2013 BCM-HGSC/Dbia_2.0,"
enter "tra-pa," into the search
terms field and then click "submit." We are now
navigating to the genomic region that contains
the presumed tra ortholog in the Drosophila
biarmipes whole genome assembly and will examine
the evidence tracks for the presumed ortholog.
Scroll down to the RNA Seq Tracks section
and then change the display mode for the
modENCODE TopHat Junctions track to "pack"
to view the individual splice junctions.
After clicking "refresh," we now see a single
track with the collection of all TopHat
splice junction predictions from the mixed
embryos, adult female, and adult male samples.
In order to create this track, splice junction
predictions from the different libraries
are filtered and then merged together. The
predictions are color-coded to indicate the
number of spliced RNA reads that support the
predicted splice junction. Red indicates that
there are more than one thousand spliced RNA-Seq
reads supporting the junction, followed by brown,
pink, green, blue, and black in descending order,
with black corresponding to fewer than 10 reads.
Several other evidence tracks are
available under the RNA Seq Tracks section.
You may click on the track title link above
the display mode drop down list to learn more
about how that evidence track was created and the
display convention used by that particular track.